Haftbefehl wird ein zweites Mal zu
klicksum kommen ich habe es ihm
versprochen denn im letzten Jahr als
wenn interviewt haben da gab es nichts
zu promoten normalerweise machen das
Künstler dann gar nicht aber für
klicksum hat eine Ausnahme gemacht und
jetzt kommt das versprochene zweite
Interview zu seinem Album kanakisch das
äh in diesen Tagen erscheinen wird
endlich heiß ersehen mit spannenden
Features mit denen der ein oder andere
so wahrscheinlich nicht gerechnet hat da
werden wir heute hoffentlich äh drüber
reden können und wir reden natürlich
über eure Fragen wenn ihr sie am besten
per Video Antwort stellt die
Videobeschreibung unten liest und auch
beherzigt und kreativ seid dann steht
euren Frage bzw Antwort Glück nichts
mehr im Wege bis dann